[Musique]
car si république cheikh sportif
olympique ou pas dans six mois tokyo
accueille lé giro une compétition pour
laquelle l' agence mondiale antidopage a
exclu la russie motif une présumée
falsification de données pour faire
passer pour négative des tests positifs
moscou nous contestent et c'est le
tribunal arbitral du sport qui va devoir
trancher
mais cette affaire soulève des questions
après le précédent scandale né du
rapport mclaren en 2014 après la mise au
ban des athlètes russes lors des
derniers mondiaux d'athlétisme au qatar
pourquoi nouvelle polémique
pourquoi un état entier et il visé et
non des individualités
pourquoi la russie le dopage scandale
sportif ou arme politique
on en parle après le générique
[Musique]
bienvenue sur arte france pour un nouvel
épisode de l'autre match à six mois des
jeux olympiques de tokyo j'accueille sur
ce plateau avec carole gomez vous êtes
chercheur à l'iris l'institut
des relations stratégiques
internationales à vous êtes spécialiste
du sport dans les relations
internationales
et bonjour est à vos côtés et claude
blanchou maison si l'ambassadeur de
france en russie au début des années
2000 et auteur du livre vivre avec
poutine aux éditions temporis bonjour
bonjour avant de rentrer dans le vif du
sujet cette question toute simple le
dopage arme politique ou scandale
sportif carlos gomes je dirais que c'est
une arme c'est plutôt un scandale en ce
cas clairement de sportifs
majoritairement sportif oui c'est
évidemment un scandale sportif puisque
sa fausse toutes les compétitions et
c'est évidemment contraire à l'idéal
olympique
maintenant ça peut être utilisée est
manipulée à des fins politiques
mais justement à partir de quand tout
cela remonte je vous propose un recap
pour comprendre un petit peu la genèse
de tout ça février 2014 lors des jeux
olympiques d'hiver de sotchi en russie
des dizaines d'échantillons d'athlètes
rues sont remplacés par des prélèvements
dits propres notamment par grigori
rodtchenko of le directeur du
laboratoire antidopage de moscou en mai
2016 le new york times révèle le
scandale des jo de sotchi en se basant
sur les aveux de gregorio chunk of qui
depuis a fui aux états unis juillet 2016
le rapport mclaren confirme les soupçons
de dopage d'état entre 2011 et 2015
l' agence antidopage russe la rue sada
et déclaré non conforme par l' agence
mondiale antidopage 2018 l'aema
réintègre la russa da contre la promesse
de récupérer les données techniques
conserver au laboratoire de moscou
janvier 2019 la russie transmet ces
données septembre 2019
après analyse de ces dernières la emma
annonce avoir identifié deux probables
manipulation du 9 décembre 2019
la m a exclu la russie des jeux
olympiques d'été à tokyo en 2020 d'hiver
à pékin en
22 ainsi que de toute grande compétition
mondiale 27 décembre 2019 la russe anna
annonce avoir envoyé sa lettre formelle
contestant l'exclusion de la russie des
compétitions sportives mondiales pour
avoir falsifié une base de données
antidopage voilà donc pour ce calendrier
jusqu'à aujourd'hui car le gomes mais va
falloir encore attendre pour avoir les
véritables réponses effectivement
puisque donc cette cette demande en
appel a été transmise à l'agencé
mondiale antidopage qui elle même doit
se reporter vers le tribunal arbitral du
sport et on estime à peu près que là la
réponse finale de ceux de ce contentieux
interviendra à aux alentours de l'été
2020 dont va à peu près six mois
justement entre il ya les jeux
olympiques de tokyo claude blanchemaison
la russie selon vous sera t-elle exclus
est ce qu'on va voir comme au jeu de
pyongyang des athlètes russes sous
drapeau olympique
j'espère que non mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya une suspicion systémique sur le
laboratoire russe puisque le précédent
directeur a fait des révélations
il a fui à l'étranger pour faire ces
révélations et pour l'épauler confirmé
et puis le directeur actuel n'est pas
loin de de faire aussi des révélations à
10 ans il ya quand même un grand ménage
à faire dans les fédérations de sport
russe alors c'est un peu singulier que
le directeur du laboratoire national
tiennent des propos de ce type le
présent on parle d'eux
du nouveau il s'agit de youri ghana
c'est de l'ancien s'était tu as fait se
retient tout à fait alors c'est curieux
que le second qui a été nommé par le
gouvernement russe dans le fond
persistent et signent alors de façon
peut-être moins incisive que son
prédécesseur qui est parti qui est qui
parce qu'il fut à l'étranger mais quand
même il le laisse entendre qu'il y a en
effet un grand ménage à faire dans les
fédérations sportives russe et peut-être
même dans le propre dans son propre
laboratoire qu'il dirige jusqu'à quel
point le dirige-t-il fait le paradoxe
comment un directeur peut-il dénoncer
des pratiques dans une institution dont
il est dont il a la charge est un peu
paradoxale ça peut arriver en russie
carole commerce là on voit derrière vous
des athlètes avec cette bannière neutre
cette bannière olympique on se souvient
à pyeonchang lors des jeux d'hiver en
corée du sud
il y avait une fameuse
bagnères oar ça voulait dire olympic
athlètes of russia avec un ours qui
symbolise donc du coup la russie est ce
que ça va encore être le cas du coup
l'été prochain alors vrai sens de la
mode ce sera sans doute le cas en
sachant qu' il est si on relit le
communiqué de l'agencé mondiale
antidopage
il est indiqué que des athlètes pourront
participer à deux conditions
la première c'est que il n'est pas
participer il n'est pas été impliqué
directement dans le dernier scandale
dans la falsification des différents
fichiers et échantillons qui ont été
remis à l'agencé mondiale antidopage et
d'autre part qu'ils arrivent à démontrer
qu'ils n'ont absolument jamais été de
près ou de loin impliqué dans ce dans ce
scandale de dopage dont qu'il est
vraiment charge à eux d'arriver à
prouver leur innocence
pour arriver à participer à ces
compétitions olympiques et paralympiques
donc là il n'ya pas d'innocence
effectivement dans ce cas là on pourrait
penser que la charge que quelqu'un lui
la présomption d'innocence pourrait
pourrait être être de mise
là c'est plutôt au contraire à charge
aux athlètes d'arriver à démontrer
qu'ils n'ont jamais pris part à ces
assez à ce scandale et qu'ils n'ont
jamais été impliqués de près ou de loin
au sein de leur fédération au sein de
leur club dans une de ses amies qui
n'ont jamais bénéficié de ces 2 c
de ces programmes de dopage la pelouse
blanchie maison tout à l'heure vous
parliez des directeurs successifs de la
roue sa dalle lagence antidopage russe
donc rodtchenko off et du régal où ce
jeu vous propose de regarder un extrait
d'un documentaire qui est à voir
d'ailleurs sur arte france pro tv ou sur
l'antenne de rtl france qui s'appelle
justement les dossiers interdit est
dedans il y à du riz à nous et il ya
également le ministre russe des sports
révèle que le prof extraits
selon le chef de la rue sade à des
milliers de tests antidopage ont été
falsifiés un fonctionnaire russe affirme
que la russie a modifié des milliers de
résultats de contrôles antidopage sa
participation au giro est en jeu le chef
de l'agencé russe anti dopage à critique
sa propre fédération d'athlétisme
il affirme que la vieille garde au sein
de cette organisation empêche de mettre
de l'ordre
tiago carriço ceux qui critiquent vos
déclarations récentes disent en gros que
vous aller plus vite que la musique
je sais parfaitement qui dit cela
ils ne veulent qu être réintégré le plus
vite possible la emma n'a pas encore
officiellement accusé la russie de
manipulation des tests antidopage
donc avec vos déclarations vous avez
encore un peu plus compliqué la
situation je ne suis pas qu'ils la
compliquent et vous avec vos
déclarations formidable j'ai déjà
entendu ça après avoir fait mes
déclarations gagnent us a détruit
l'athlétisme c'est n'importe quoi
ce sont des mensonges qui la détruit
yuri gagne s'entraîne sans raison un
millier d'athlètes dans une discussion
sur des sujets pour lesquels il ne
dispose pas d'information complet c'est
une rhétorique fait pour dénigrer le
fait est que c'est un coup dur pour la
réputation de notre sport
du reggae à nous ce qu'ils dénoncent
donc des falsifications
on entend le journaliste dire
de certains pensent qu'il va plus vite
que la musique au final qui croire karl
gomez
c'est assez compliqué d'arriver à y voir
clair dans cette dans cette affaire
puisque d'un côté on a un ministre des
sports qui les font ministre des sports
et l'ensemble de l'exécutif russe ans
qui défend les athlètes et qui nie tout
tout scandale institutionnalisée au
niveau du sport russe alors que de notre
côté on a le chef de la russe anna qui
lui met le bout de bois sur un certain
nombre de dysfonctionnements et qui au
final a tendance à considérer que ce qui
arrive
et cette décision de l'agencé mondiale
antidopage aussi dure soit elle est
quelque part un peu méritée et
permettrait de mettre de mettre un peu
en coup de pied dans la fourmilière
permettant de réformer en profondeur le
sport russe et 2 ainsi gommé un certain
nombre de deux choses qui ne vont pas il
est très compliqué d'arriver à essayer
de comprendre un petit peu le jeu qui
est un lieu actuellement entre ces deux
entre ces deux ces deux idées ce
d'autant plus que on assez peu
d'informations sur la personnalité de 2
gano si on ne sait pas exactement quel
est son agenda
certains considèrent que c'est une façon
de
de véritablement se faire changer en
profondeur son institution d'autres
considèrent que au contraire il s'agit
peut-être de venir faire tampon et
porter la faute sur un un acteur plutôt
qu'un autre et donc de mieux ainsi
pouvoir rebondir dans les dents les dans
les prochaines dans les prochaines
semaines et les prochains mois
et encore beaucoup de beaucoup
d'interrogations la seule chose que l'on
peut dire c'est qu'on ne sait pas
véritablement s'il s'agit de billard à
une bande ou plutôt à plusieurs claude
blanchou maison on parle de cette
affaire avec l'exécutif sur le comex
viens viens d'en parler
dmitri medvedev à parler d'hystérie
antirusse devenue chronique est
également un petit peu plus tard je
crois c'est le 18 des formes il y avait
eu vous l'a dit mir poutine qui tenait
sa conférence annuelle
face aux médias une question lui a été
posée à ce sujet il a répondu pourquoi
est-ce qu'on sanctionne un état et pas
les individualités au final que retenir
de ce positionnement qui a un problème
de gouvernance en russie dans le domaine
du sport puisque le ministre et le
gouvernement ne disent pas la même chose
que le chef de l' agence ses premiers
première de gouvernance le deuxième
c'est que le chef de l' agence ne tient
pas sa boutique ne tient pas sa maison
puisqu'il dénonce les pratiques qui
serait une pratique de la vieille garde
qui continueraient à trafiquer comme on
le faisait à l'époque de l'union
soviétique
les analyses ou en tout cas les
prélèvements donc il ya un problème et
il faut qu'à un moment donné un peu
d'ordre soit mis d'abord dans l' agence
et puis ensuite dans la cohérence entre
ce que déclare le gouvernement russe est
ce que déclare le le chef de l' agence
alors par ailleurs je crois que vladimir
poutine comme comme assez souvent
d'ailleurs 30 une ligne assez
raisonnable il ne dit pas il n'y a pas
eu de dopage et il dit il faut punir les
individus il a il a raison donc il faut
punir quelqu'un il n'est pas n'y a pas
eu de pages parce que autrefois la
position de défense était un mur c'était
il ya le dopage n'existe pas russie dino
c'est possible mais à cela il faut punir
les individus et il faut d'abord que ce
soient les fédérations russe qui les
sanctionnent donc c'est aussi un
avertissement à donner aux fédération
russe de sports et peut-être
à l' agence antidopage russes pour leur
dire faites votre métier
tout à l'heure vous nous disiez il n'y a
pas de présomption d'innocence est ce
qu'il ya condamnation avant jugement
carole gomez
non puisqu'il ya aussi aussi le
l'objectif de ces de cet appel devant le
tribunal arbitral du sport qui est
confronté quotidiennement sur ces
notamment sur des questions d'harper fin
de deux pages par contre il ya quelque
chose qui me qui me semble qu il me
semble important pour vraiment bien
comprendre cette cette affaire là c'est
qu'on a tendance à se focaliser
aujourd'hui sur les derniers épisodes
les derniers soubresauts de 7,2 cette
affaire et comme le montrent et très
bien votre votre petite vidéo
d'introduction c'est quelque chose qui
remonte à très longtemps dont les
allemands avec avec un documentaire delà
de la télévision allemande qui suivait
des lanceurs d'alerté russes qui avaient
fui la russie et qui s'était confié à la
télévision allemand pour le dire à quel
point notamment dans le domaine de
l'athlétisme n'est plus plus exactement
aussi à l'échelle de de la deûle agence
antidopage
il y avait un vrai problème de
gouvernance et qu'on n'était pas sûr
quelques scandales de dopage mais plutôt
un scandale beaucoup plus large et ce
qui semble aussi intéressant de
souligner c'est qu'il ya eu différents
moments forts de tension palpable dans
cette sur cette affaire là 2014
évidemment mais également il ya eu des
révélations qui sont intervenus avec le
rapport aux mclaren qui sont atteints
d'une deux ans après et cette dernière
année 2010 9 avait vraiment été avait
pour objectif de venir essayer de 2
d'apaiser un peu et de non pas passer à
autre chose mais de redonner une
nouvelle chance à la russie de
réintégrer parfaitement et intégralement
nu des sportifs quand on regarde les
sportifs
exactement et donc c'était aussi dans
cette la date que vous avez cités c'est
dès janvier 2019 qui était aussi cette
idée de d ok on va essayer de clôturer
la faire vous nous faites passer un
certain nombre de deux d'échantillons et
ça permet aussi de vérifier devait rimer
véritablement fermer cette parenthèse
dossier très compliqué on l'a bien
compris ça tombe bien une reste du temps
pour continuer à en parler c'est la
pause en revient dans un str de retour
sur le plateau de l'autre match pour
parler du dopage avec carole gomez
spécialiste de la géopolitique du sport
à l'iris et claude blanchou maison
ancien ambassadeur de france à moscou
on évoquait des problèmes de gouvernance
à plusieurs échelons
j'ai envie de poser la question de la
légitimité de la hem à l'agencé mondiale
antidopage la wada en anglais puisqu'il
ya le conseil de fondation l'instance
suprême décisionnaires de de l'aema elle
est composée de 38 membres pas de russe
et puis il ya également le comité de la
révision de la conformité qui a émis ses
recommandations pour donc exclure la
russie lors des prochains jeux qui est
composé de six membres la hausse il n'y
a pas de rossi l'a beaucoup de pays
occidentaux qu'est ce qu'il faut en
retenir à ce que la m1 est elle
réellement légitime
mon sens oui puisqu'elle a été créée de
façon collective et collégial ou juste
après le scandale de la festina en 1998
où il ya vraiment eu cette réflexion de
ne pas traiter le dopage d'un point de
vue purement national mais au contraire
d'avoir une approche internationale et
donc si des reproches parfois tout à
fait justifiée peuvent être faits au
niveau de la gestion de la lenteur
parfois ou du manque de moyens dont la
map peut disposer
je ne suis pas sûr qu'on puisse remettre
en cause de sa légitimité
sans compter que les différents rapports
qui sont intervenus justement sur sur le
sur le cas sur le cac russes ont été
faits par
des personnes dont la connaissance du
milieu sportif est indéniable et
apparemment alors j'ai plus les éléments
tête mais apparemment il y avait quand
même un certain nombre de rencontres au
sein de fédération russe avec des
athlètes russes mais également à
l'échelle internationale qui avait été
organisée pour justement venir
consolider ce rapport colle blanche
maison le sport est très politique et
très géo politique
quel est le rapport de force entre les
états via le sport c'est pas nouveau que
le fun le fait que la politique faciale
options dans les grandes compétitions
sportives ça n'est pas nouveau
évidemment aussi de toujours l'exemple
des jeux olympiques de berlin en 1936
que hitler avait réussi à détourner et
que les films le film notamment de
feindre il faut juste à la glorifier
donc ça n'est pas une affaire nouvelle
on le sait bien
ce qui est nouveau quand même c'est que
avec la les moyens nouveaux de
communication avec la télévision avec
internet tout le monde a accès aux
compétitions et tout le monde a accès
aux débats y compris à ce débat sur le
dopage
donc ça c'est complètement nouveau
autrefois ça se passait en vase clos et
finalement c'était des milieux très
confiné d'ailleurs d'une certaine
manière la composition du cio on est
parfois encore un petit peu le reflet
malheureusement c'est un petit peu un
petit peu une image du passé
aujourd'hui tout ça est ouvert et les
opinions publiques nationales et
internationales interviennent mais
évidemment une opinion publique
nationale se mobilisent
si ces équipes nationales sont
sanctionnés et seront sanctionnés
collectivement donc bien entendu là
aujourd'hui
probablement que l'opinion russe a
l'impression que la russie est maltraité
qu'elle est traitée de façon 1
juste c'est logique qu'une recrue une
opinion publique réagissent delà de
cette manière alors sur le fond on verra
bien puisqu'il ya encore des recours qui
sont en cours en réalité et on verra
bien quel sera le jugement je crois
qu'en réalité tout le monde respecte les
et des experts en effet de l'aema la
composition elle résulte d'un consensus
après tout la russie peut aussi faire
des efforts pour en devenir membre un
jour mais peut-être faut-il faire des
efforts aussi dans ce cas là en matière
de de dopage et 2 et 2 et de système
instauré dans certaines fédérations
la russie occupe
la tête d'affiché si j'ose dire dans le
dopage en ce moment en tous les cas sur
de nombreux médias pourquoi les yeux
rivés sur un état et pas sur les autres
j'ai envie de dire ça c'est peut-être
une question aussi de toute temporalité
il ya toujours eu des scandales de
dopage
et c'est aussi ça qui a fait progresser
la lutte antidopage après là où ça me
paraît peut-être un peu un peu différent
ici et si c'est aussi ça qui qui fait
peut-être la différence sur le
traitement c'est que s'il ya eu des
affaires par exemple affaire balco
concernées vraiment laboratoire est le
lien entre le l'état américain et le
laboratoire balco n'a jamais pu être
réellement établie là il ya de sûr le
cas ici qui nous intéresse
d'après le rapport de
mclaren d'après les révélations de
rodtchenko et un certain nombre de
lanceurs d'alerté il semblerait qu'il ya
un lien entre l'état et ce programme de
ce programme de dopage et ce qui en ce
moment la période récente sur laquelle
preuve selon les preuves qui ont été
apportés par les deux enfin l'athlète
est la personne qui travaillait au sein
du laboratoire russe anna qui sont
ensuite partis en
en allemagne pour justement se protéger
des différentes représailles rodtchenko
fait également
c'est aussi très largement détaillés
dans le rapport mclaren où il y avait un
ensemble de faisceau d'indicés qui
considère qu' il était impossible que au
moins l'autorité du ministre des sports
n'était pas été au courant qu'ils
étaient vitali moutko à l'époque dont on
sait l'importance dans le dans
l'exécutif russe est donc là encore on
peut difficilement imaginer que un
dispositif de cette ampleur là ne puisse
pas
nenê pas eu une panne validation mais il
n'est pas ce ne soit pas arrivé aux
oreilles des dés
de l'exécutif là encore rien n'est
tranché rien n'est officiellement la
justice n'a pas été rendue sur ce point
là et donc c'est aussi pour ça qu'il va
falloir non seulement relire avec
attention les différents rapports qui
avaient été publiés mais surtout
attendre la validation ou l'invalidation
de la décision de l'agencé mondiale anti
dopage par le tribunal arbitral du sport
et c'est ça qui va être vraiment
intéressant pour voir si potentiellement
ya de nouvelles pièces qui vont être
apportées et c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a
dit la russa d'art en disant que ça
permettait cet appel permettait de
mettre en avant des pièces qui n'avaient
pas forcément été mises en suffisamment
utilisé selon eux au cours des
différentes procédures et que ça
permettait vraiment de réunir en même
instance
l'ensemble des pièces à charge et à
décharge qui permettait d'établir la
réalité sur ce sur ce fait là on voit
derrière vous des photos de laboratoire
on pense forcément que le blanchemaison
aux industries pharmaceutiques on a
l'impression que il ya une fuite en
avant
par rapport à cette industrie que
finalement les sciences officieuse
devance toujours la science officielle
est ce qu'il ya un lobby là dedans à
fait clair que la biochimie et les
biotechnologies font les progrès tous
les jours et ce qui est bien
sauf lorsque c'est lorsqu'elle se met au
service de mauvaises causes comme par
exemple le page des sportifs mais bien
sûr le jeu pour un certain nombre de
laboratoires consiste à trouver de
nouvelles formules et surtout à trouver
nouvelle formule difficile à détecter
qui ne sont pas détectables par la
technologie dont on dispose à l'instant
t
donc c'est une espèce de course
permanente pour découvrir de nouvelles
formules d'action biochimiques
biotechnologique qu'on ne pourra pas
détecté qu'on n'a pas encore appris à
développer une économie souterraine dans
tous alors effectivement bien sûr il ya
évidemment une compétition entre les
grands laboratoires mondiaux dans dans
ce domaine et peut-être l'at-il qui est
une action dans ce domaine
peut-être l'at-il qu'ils signent une
charte une charte morale pour s'engager
à ne pas jouer ce jeu de la compétition
pour le dopage des sportifs on a parlé
beaucoup de l' agence mondiale
antidopage ama
peut bien rapport très récemment pour
savoir quels étaient les pays les plus
concernées par le dopage
éléments de réponse avec quémander quoi
+ 13 % de cas de dopage en 2017 le
rapport annuel de l'agencé mondiale
antidopage inquiète 1804 cas recensés
dans 93 au sport contre 1595 en 2016 et
parmi les pays les plus concernés
l'italie avec 171 cas la france les
états unis le brésil et la russie
le sport le plus touché n'est pas
forcément celui auquel on s'attend le
culturisme et la discipline le dopage
civile plus avec 266 cas suivi de très
près par l'athlétisme et le cyclisme
le foot lui est sixième le rugby 8e sur
les 1800 quatre cas de dopage relevés en
2010 7459 ont été détectés grâce à des
résultats des analyses
le reste provient d'un travail d'enquêté
de renseignement voilà donc l'italie
première la france deuxième ensuite ils
les etats-unis le brésil la russie qui
vient finalement plus loin s'il ya pas
une justice à deux vitesses alors en
l'occurrence
il faut encore voir comment est ce que
je suis pas sûr qu'on puisse faire une
comparaison entre ces entre ces deux
éléments là même si c'est effectivement
essentiel de rappeler que le fait de
pointer du doigt la russie et de
considérer qu'elle est la seule à
potentiellement avoir recours au dopage
à mon sens c'est vraiment faire fi de la
réalité de l'image tout entière et donc
c'est aussi important d'avoir ce genre
de données là qui sont au final assez
assez révélatrice de l'état actuel du
sport qui est touchée absolument partout
dans toutes les disciplines
dans tous les pays et pas l'apanage de
certaines disciplines dans certains dans
certains pays donc c'est aussi ça qu'il
faut à mon sens retenir même si sur le
cadet alors j'ai pas en tête les
procédures concernant les centres 71 cas
italien
mais ce qui concerne les caps français
il ya une procédure qui est très clair
avec une suspension sportive voire même
un déni suivi pénale des sanctions
pénales qui sont d'ailleurs ce palmarès
est peut-être le palmarès des sanctions
puisque en effet comment sait-on qu'il
ya eu autant de de tant de personnes de
paix dans un pays c'est en général parce
qu'elles ont été repérés et donc
sanctionné et en français le sont
systématiquement sanctionnés en tout cas
je l'espère par l' agence antidopage
françaises et par les fédérations et est
ce que quand on voit tout ça est ce
qu'on se dit c'est pays bas italie
france etats unis ce qui doivent aussi
être exclu de compétition internationale
la question doit se poser si
en fait ce qui est ce qui justifie la
décision de l'agencé mondiale antidopage
ça a été la répétition d'un certain
nombre d'infractions qu'a pu connaître
le laboratoire russe anna et notamment
aussi le fait que ce soit et le terme
est utilisé dans le rapport mclaren
c'est un dopage est systémique c'est à
dire que c'est pas une personne qui
décide pour des raisons qui lui sont
propres de prendre des produits dopants
pour justement performer sur le terrain
là il est vraiment une
un élément beaucoup plus systémique est
à mon sens il ya aussi un élément qui
est assez intéressant qui est aussi lié
à la diplomatie sportive russe dans le
cadre des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de sotchi organisé en 2014
et elle est vraiment cette volonté de
performer or on sait qu'en 2010 lors des
jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
vancouver
la russie a fait l'un des plus mauvais
scores un terme au tableau des médailles
elle était 11e et corrélation ou pas on
a pu voir des progrès importants
réalisés par les athlètes à partir dès
2011 et certains
même si là encore j'ai j'ai pas vu le
rapport officiel sur ces éléments là
mais on dans le rapport mc la faim dans
le rapport aux mclaren il est
sous-entendu que il ya vraiment ce set
cette mise en place cette discussion
importante au sein de l'état russe qui
apparaît à partir de ce moment là l'idée
étant de faire de ces jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de sotchi un vrai
événement réussi d'un point de vue
organisationnel
d'un point de vue la culture mais
également d'avoir des performances
puisqu'on sait que pendant le défunt au
tableau des médailles
la russie a terminé première avec
presque le double de médailles et après
avec les athlètes qui ont été blanchis
elle a réussi à récupérer sa première
place au tableau des médailles de sotchi
de sotchi puis tout a faim on arrive à
la fin de l'émission évidemment c'est un
sujet compliqué avec plein de ficelle à
droite et à gauche
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison
d'avoir répondu à nos questions merci
également à carole gomez émission à
revoir en podcast ou en replay sur arte
france point tv puis évidemment ce
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouvel épisode de l'autre match
[Musique]